There's one important problem with using the sum of
the squared error to evaluate your regression.
I'll show it to you now.
Here are two different data sets, and the regression line for each one of them.
And here's a quiz question.
Which one of these regressions is doing a better job of
fitting the patterns in the data?
They're two slightly different data sets, but you can still make a comparison,
but they're not so different you couldn't compare them, at least by eye.
So do you think the one on the left is doing a better job of fitting the data,
the one on the right is doing a better job of fitting the data,
or would you say they're probably about the same?
I haven't defined what better means very precisely here and
I've kind of done that on purpose and
this is going to get to the heart of why sum of squared errors isn't perfect.
So this is a little bit of a tricky quiz, but just give it your best shot.